i was riding my bike yesterday and i was
going down this
hard decline uh flying probably 40 miles
an hour [ __ ] flying
but i'm using the brakes i don't want to
crash and so i'm using the brakes using
brakes
and i go to yeah there i am i don't be
mad at the quads i go to get off
dude the the break i don't even think
about it yeah when you're breaking
it's gonna get hot and i got off and
like just wanted to set my bike because
i was gonna get something out of my bag
the brake like caliber hit my leg
dude i thought i swear to god i thought
a rattlesnake finally got me
it was the break was steaming i mean
really piping hot
burn singed the [ __ ] on my list but i
swear to god i was like oh
it's a rattlesnake it hurt that bad
around i literally screamed out
it hurt so bad are you a
high-pitched screamer or are you like a
man i'm a cusser
oh are you [ __ ] yeah i'm that guy right
away
i am a unfortunate screamer hi my
brother won't see horror movies with me
not only am i a shrieker dude i'm going
to tell you a little bit a bit of a
[ __ ] move
i'm a jazz hander i'll meet you yeah
yeah i'll do it yeah is it weird
the jazz hand yes my jacob my son
he knows that i scream like a [ __ ] when
i get scared
so he scared me a bunch of times over
the years and i didn't know what he was
he he put a video together and it's just
like
30 scares of me going [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like that the whole thing is what a
dick dude last time i was watching the
other thing is
hot house on haunted hill i think that
wasn't that scary
netflix show it's so good part two is
coming in october
part two uh 2020 october but uh
house on i know on that that was a video
game the the
house on notting hill something like
that i think that's right but there's a
scene in there spoiler in three
two one there's a scene in there towards
the end
where they're just they're taught like
it's a ghost that haunts them right
and they're just talking the car and you
like you know when there's like the
music or there's a build up yeah like
something scary so you kind of brace
yourself
and we're just what me and my girl
sitting there watching on the couch and
i get my arm around her
and i'm like yes movies this show is
kind of boring like it was good
and then something pops out out of where
you didn't expect
dude i [ __ ] did like this i brought
my leg up like this i was like yeah
my girl's like oh my god i was so
embarrassed
what is what is the type of haunted
movie
because saw and movies like that they
don't the gore
they don't scare me they don't scare me
like hostile scares me hustle two scares
because that probably really goes
anything that i think could possibly
even a one percent chance of scaring the
[ __ ] out of me like annabelle the con
oh dude any demon stuff you gotta watch
this netflix here
really oh dude is it if you like scary
yeah it's like that yeah it's
this this house that these kids grew up
in it's haunted but never really leaves
them it's so good
what was that movie yeah where the
people showed up
i think it was based on a true story
where those people showed up at a house
some people were renting in masks
oh i know what you're talking about
strangers was it called the stranger
you're invited oh no strangers i think
you're right i think strangers you like
scary movies
stuff too cat yeah yeah i love it that
movie
anything where it could happen
really that's it yeah that was [ __ ]
scary anything where it could happen
like even the first purge is a little
scary dude that could definitely
we're kind of moving that way what's
your move on the purge if you have 24
hours what's your move
uh rent a boat and get out get out i'm
gonna run as soon as like hey purge
in three months i'm going to marina del
rey paying whatever it takes to rent a
boat
for the next five months i'm going out
there yeah i'm not
i'm not i'm not pretending to be tough
guy no there's no
that's not my movement i'm not i'm
getting a boat we're out of here yeah
yeah whatever city is not doing it
flying me there listen dude you're
talking
two guys one guy who matches his
kerchief to his shirt yeah dude
yeah i don't wanna i don't partake in
any of it and another dude
you would kill somebody can you imagine
killing like even my worst enemy what
no no i can't even kill animals like
like i'll teach my son not to like his
grandma that there's ants there's time
to step on him
and then we're outside yesterday and
he's like papa ants he started stepping
like what the [ __ ]
are you doing we don't kill ants dude
dude he's like why i'm like we don't
kill anything
we kill nothing do you like no spiders i
catch i release
really unless there's like a rattlesnake
in the house
but it even i catch spiders i release
them i don't step on ants
i don't hit bees outdoors this is your
territory outdoors you're outdoors i'm
not going to kill you
unless it's one of those wasps with abs
done if it's one of those fornates
that's brian calls them
abs and it won't leave your family alone
well then i gotta end it dude
because now you're a threat to the fan
but when it when a when a bee
buzzes your tower are you calm cool and
collected nope
terrified of bees me too one is that one
of those oh if one of those hornates
decides to come around the family i'm
gonna have to execute you buddy why does
that dude's thumb look at the size of
his thumb that's a big ass [ __ ]
good god how how about my father-in-law
was trying to be cool around my son
whereby the pool for the reason there's
you know bees do their thing i don't
know if they're drinking water or
whatever
but they're like floating around and
he's like yeah they're harmless they
won't do anything and one was like
zoom around my son's let my son scare
him because i'm scared of him so he's
like oh let's be scared
so his grandpa my father-in-law was like
no don't you don't have to worry about
seeing
he's like you catch him throw him and he
goes look
the thing bit the stung the [ __ ] out i'm
like dude what
are you thinking dude when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song